well the stars and stripes at half-mast  here for yet another mass shooting in  the united states we're in a pretty  affluent suburb of chicago here in  illinois  and you can see a really quite stark  scene  the bits and pieces of an independence  day parade a very very stark  illustration of just how quickly people  had to run literally for their lives  shoes  chairs  flags even prams as well this was a  family day out as it was and has been  across the country but here just before  lunch time as the pr as the parade was  about to begin or the great parade had  just got underway  a gunman opened fire unbelievably  frightening yet another mass shooting  once again all those questions and  introspection about guns in america